that's right this family and since for
we're putting the dirtiest meanest
humans all into one house where they
will thrive on trash and live to ruin
other people's lives
let us begin the husband they'll have a
snobby artist vibe and a little bit on
the slim side oh shut up now you're
getting a weird belly and but you snob
aspiration definitely public enemy
number one lifestyle slob mean and will
go with a heavy eater first-name Falco
family name bang galore angle on meat
Falco Bangalore his wife opposites
attract right so I'm thinking thin head
small eyes skinny I see her as a
recovering death metal groupie she's got
to be a mean slob as well but we've
spice it up with little noncommittal
tendencies meat
mughal ax i know these names suck but so
will this family right here they are for
the very first time Falco and Mughal ah
Bangalore you two need to get
comfortable before we start pumping out
any babies oh how nice look at them this
is so great
okay now how about some jobs Falco
you're gonna be an aspiring artist and a
Mughal oh you're getting back on stage
baby oh I guess Falco doesn't like
Mughal uh getting back in the biz well
let's fix this house up huh it's pretty
bland oh Jesus Falco we are not off to a
good start buddy Falco you're very tense
huh well yeah you're on fire okay you
two need to get out of the house time to
mingle but more importantly time to make
some friends
sooo vanilla very Moog Allah you can't
sleep there are you guys always so tired
oh I forgot to give you guys a bed my
bad guys let's renovate let's show the
neighborhood who the Bangalore's really
are a fun tasteful family so I already
started with some stone walls to reflect
your cold lifeless hearts do you like
that move Allah great I'm gonna put some
lights and signs in to attract the
neighbors so it'll look good at night as
well hmm
no one's coming that's fine we'll come
to them Falco knock on that door and see
if anyone's home yep
good call just go right in yeah make
yourselves at home guys Liberty Lee here
just said you're close with Lex
nice call I do that too where's Malcolm
Falco come on buddy you guys socialize
go get
baby
oh yeah Wow it's 5:00 a.m. already
the bangalore's sure know how to party
okay move Allah I think we've overstayed
our welcome time to head home and get
some rest
it's been quite the day the bangalore is
everyone there great huh
next time on the bangalore's falco takes
out his money problems by pissing on the
sidewalk and denying he did it muga lows
marriage been put on the line when she
meets the handsome Bobby Anderson and we
get to meet the three new bangalore
children there's the very pretty and
popular far Glee her smart and witty
sister Gary and then there's the little
rascal the little ball of sunshine Carl
or the bangalore's
you